[Music]  we have a great partnership here with  tbs we get along very well with the  company and recently they asked me if i  could develop  more programming for their network which  is very i was it was a real honor i was  like wow guys this is cool we worked  hard we came up with a new reality show  that i think they're going to love i  think america is going to love it take a  look  from the producers of big brother comes  a new reality show that will open your  eyes  coma house  12 competitors come in but only one will  come out  and they'll stop at nothing to win the 1  000 prize  experience all the drama  the laughter  and all the hot uncensored hookups you  can handle  personalities clash as alliances are  formed  and broken only on tds's coma house  [Applause]